thank you good morning this morning I
would like to talk about how HTTP
applications are just a quasi function
from a streaming request to a
polymorphic effect of a streaming
response so what's the problem a few
words about myself I'm not going to read
all of this to you I'll throw in a
couple of bonus facts on top of what's
already on the slide first of all I am
very much an introvert second of all I
was born and raised in the Midwest and
the reason I tell you both of those as
they both relate and the fact that I
hate talking about myself and cannot
wait to get started talking about the
code so let's go do it
what is HTTP 4 s so HTTP 4s was started
by a bunch of us sculpture developers
that's a project that I used to work on
and we were very tightly coupled to the
servlet API at the time there was no way
to run Schelotto without talking
directly to httpservletrequest
httpservletresponse and we had a lot of
people who wanted to run it on a nutty
back-end at the time and we looked
around in other languages and every
other language has this concept where
you've got a mapping of a request to a
response maybe it's a pure function with
types or maybe it's just this abstract
definition where you've got dynamic
types and things can be impure but
almost every other language he has an
enclosure you've got rig and ruby you've
got react Python has WSGI our closest
cousin is Haskell that he has W AI there
was nothing like that in Scala so we set
out to build that for Scala and as far
as that our initial goal went we failed
kind of miserably because today
sculpture does not run on HTTP for s and
we don't have a nutty back-end for HTTP
for us
however conceptually we were very
successful in that so an HTTP for s API
it can be defined in multiple ways we've
got a DSL that we provide as part of the
core package that's based on pattern
matching it looks a lot like unfiltered
which has a tradition here in the
Northeast we have another way of
expressing API is called Rho which does
a bunch of type level style of
computations and you're able to take
your service definition and compile it
down directly into swagger documentation
and if you don't want all that type
level hackery and if you don't want any
syntactic sugar for extractor so you can
just write things as a pure function as
well and you can take all of those kinds
of API definitions and you can run them
on your choice of back-end
so we provided something called blaze
one of our contributors Bryce Anderson
wrote that it's an N i/o library it sits
in about the same space as Neddy but he
wanted to learn how to do ni oh he
thought he could do better than Neddy I
don't know that he did better than Neddy
but he did very well and it works well
for us so that's our native back-end and
we also have jetty and Tomcat
so if you want to run on a roster of
like container if you still do war
deployments here in 2018 we got you
covered on that too as far as a client
goes we have the same model for requests
and responses that you can use both on
the server side and on the client side
so we offer a client also on top of our
blaze back-end that's the one that most
people use we also have a wrapper around
a sync HTTP client and we hopefully have
more on the way for both of those so
what we're going to do is we're going to
start out with a very naive conception
of what it is to be an HTTP application
we're gonna say and it should be
application is just a function from a
request to a response how far can we get
with something as simple as that
let's define a hello world API and we're
going to just use pattern matching for a
request and responses it's a nice simple
way that we can develop some API is here
together in a slideshow so if you post
to the hello endpoint we're going to
capture the name that you post and we're
going to respond with hello otherwise we
respond with that phone
fairly easy to read let's go ahead and
unit test this and we post to the hello
endpoint with Boston and we get back
hello Boston as a body so we're already
seeing some of the virtues of pure
functional programming we didn't have to
fire up a server inside of CI to do
integration tests we can do very lean
unit tests we don't need to have mock
IDO to mock any complicated request and
response api's all it is is there's a
simple definition of a request a simple
definition of a response and a pure
function and it's so easy unit test it's
just a function call that's all you have
to do we already got our first benefit
of functional programming and let's load
test this this is something that if all
you're doing if you have a nice
synchronous back-end this is something
that's going to work very well for a
certain kind of a app but not everything
works that way it's very common that
when you're implementing an API you need
to make Network calls you're assembling
a response out of other things maybe
you're calling off to a network service
so let's say we have a contract of the
translation service so they translate
text for us and we've got a future based
interface for that client translator dot
future let's take that text and then we
need to turn that into an HTTP response
that doesn't work out so well because
our shapes says that we have to return a
response but we have over response in
the future so we have to await it does
it work yeah it works we can still post
with one and get back you know so that's
good but we are blocking threads so wait
is bad and you should feel bad
anytime that you find yourself having to
do a wait you have made a bad design
decision so we're going to need to
refine our conception of what an HTTP
application looks like and simple enough
let's just go ahead and say ok a lot of
our backends operate in the context of a
future so why don't we operate in the
context of the future and now we can see
when we call that future all we do is we
wait for that response to come back we
don't need to block a thread we wait for
the response to come back from that
service and we map it to an HTTP
response our unit test has changed a
little bit instead of just an assert we
need to do an async assert that's really
no big deal Scala tests and specs to and
many tests those are all good at doing
asynchronous assertions as well so
really no burden there we're testing
things in the future and now we have
something I think this is certifiably a
reactive HTTP library at this point it
works inside of futures so we're making
progress here another thing that we
often want to do is we want to combine
applications so maybe you've got a lot
of routes and you want to divide them up
conceptually like you've got two
different kinds of resources and you
want to split up the crud routes for
maintainability or maybe you've got a
standard health check endpoint that
works with your own infrastructure and
you're expecting health checks to
respond in a certain format at a certain
place and you want to compose that onto
all your services throughout your
company it's very useful to be able to
take two HTTP apps and combine them but
the signature that we have right now is
kind of hostile to that the best we can
do is we drop those wildcard cases from
our HTTP app and then what we do is we
have this combine function and what it
does is it calls the first service and
if the first service throws a match
error then we call the second service
does it work well when we post
Boston we get or sorry when we post a
hello we get hello Boston when we post -
hola we get hola Boston so yeah it works
but again we feel bad about ourselves
because this whole thing is based on
catching an exception for control flow
that isn't even documented anywhere that
it can be thrown so again we've got
something that works but it like the oh
wait it's a bad solution Scala has this
idea of partial functions which are good
with partial function what you're
expressing via the type system is I'm
saying that everything is a partial
mapping of requests to responses I don't
handle all requests but I handle these
requests so we're going to define this
idea and say the HTTP routes are a
partial function of request responses at
the end the server still needs a full
mapping so HTTP application is unchanged
but we're going to introduce this
concept of HTTP routes and when we put
that together we can see our combine
gets a lot nicer now we don't have to
catch an exception for control flow we
just have this simple or else that's
built right into partial functions now
we combine those two services and when
we combine those we get an HDPE app out
of it this is still bad because what
happens if we post to a language that
isn't supported yet we've got English we
got Spanish now we post a gluten talk
and we would expect that to be a 404 but
it's not we end up getting a crash so we
had the we kind of lied here a little
bit a partial function in Scala ends up
extending a total function so HTTP
routes is also an HTTP app when part of
the point of HTTP routes was it is not
in HTTP F you need an explicit way to
seal the service to make sure that
you're handling all of your cases so
we're going to refine our model again
HTTP app is unchanged but now HTTP
routes we're going to lift that partial
function so it always returns something
that's going to be defined for all
requests that might be defined to return
and done but it is defined for all
requests it's going to return an option
of a future of response and we'll have a
nice little wrapper here for creating
these HTTP routes we lose the literal
syntax with this but we just still pass
it a partial function directly so we can
see the syntax you'll still hear is
pretty good HDPE routes of instead of
just literal case blocks but it's still
okay our combined it got a little bit
noisier but it's
not catching exceptions so we still feel
pretty good about that and we can see
here and our HTTP app when we try to
combine it now that the signature of
combine is HTTP routes the HTTP routes
returns HTTP routes that is no longer in
HTTP yep the compiler caught our air it
says hey you need some way of completing
this you're returning an option of a
future but I need a future it's not
optional to return something so now
we're going to introduce this new
function called seal so seal is a way of
taking http routes and turning it into
an HTTP app so you're able to combine
routes you can combine as many of those
as you want if we were supporting German
we could have a third service there keep
combining them and then we can seal it
all at the end you go from HTTP routes
to an HTTP app at that point and now
we've solved our problem when we post a
guten path which isn't supported yet we
end up getting the not found just like
what we would expect instead of a crash
making progress here another thing that
you like to be able to do is composition
so I think of combination as taking
services and putting them together
horizontally composition is taking
vertically it's kind of decorating a
service with new behavior so we're going
to define this translate this is what we
called a middleware at HTTP for us it's
a function from an HTTP application to
another HTTP application and what's
going to do is it's going to take any
response body that comes back and it's
going to run it through our translator
service so now we can define services
here in the english-speaking world we
can define it with hello name and then
if we want to have a Spanish version of
the service we just wrap it inside of
our Translate middleware and now when we
post to Olaf we see that it works that
returns Ola Boston even though the
original wrap service didn't know
anything about translation practical
reasons you do composition we have a
whole bunch of middle wires defined
we've got things like for doing gzip
compression we have metrics middleware
so you can gather metrics in terms of
your response latencies there's a whole
bunch of practical applications for
composing behavior under applications in
this way now what we find is maybe we
want to be able to apply these
middlewares to a subset of our route so
right now our routing we see it's from
HTTP after
DP app it works for the entire
application but maybe we want to apply
it to a subset of our services so let's
take our hello and in English we want to
just have it be the raw routes that we
have and then we want to provide a
Spanish endpoint that we apply
translation to but we can't do that
since we've separated HTTP app from HTTP
routes we can't call these middlewares
I'm just a subset we now don't have the
same subtype relationship anymore we're
not able to do this partially so here's
where we're going to reach into cats for
the first time cats has this wonderful
thing called cly's lee it's come up a
few times already
closely as a function of a monadic value
so it's just a big wrapper around a to
an F of B and in our case the a is a
request and the B is a response let's
see how far we can get with cly's Lee
Seok wisely a type HTTP we're going to
define this new thing an HTTP function
is a function in some polymorphic effect
that's what the f means the F is just a
container or effect context there's a
bunch of words for it call what you want
it's just something that he has one type
parameter that's going to be a class Lee
in some F from a request to a response
and now we can redefine our HTTP
application is just HTTP that happens
inside the effect of a future and HTTP
routes are just HTTP that happened in
the context of an optional future we
define this case class option future
because we need something that has one
type parameter it's just so it lines up
with that HTTP shape that's a wrapper so
it fits the signature there let's see
what happens now we can define translate
and all we need out of translate is it
will work for any monad we can see that
we're taking our application and we're
flat mapping over it ACK wisely you can
flat map it and what you end up with is
you take a function of the output of the
cly's Lee the response to another cly's
Lee so we can do this function
composition using cly's Lee as long as
you have a monad and then we got our
hello just like we always have
and we try to apply that to make our
Spanish routes but it still doesn't work
it doesn't compile because it says we
couldn't find an employee
value for evidence parameter of type
cats monad option future you can't
define a monad for an option future the
option is on the outside so think about
how you had tried to define a flat map
for that it's impossible to do because
you need to know what happens in the
future to know what kind of option
return on the outside the only two ways
that you can do that or to do blocking
which we've established or bad or to
have a crystal ball which we don't have
so option future isn't going to work
future option does work so the lesson
here is that you can have two monads you
can have future and you can have option
and you can put them together and
sometimes you get a monad out sometimes
you don't it turns out if we flip these
around so the future is on the outside
we can define a monad for it so what
we're going to do is we're going to
sequence these monads so the futures on
the outside the options on the inside
redefine our service that way and now we
find that it does work now that we have
a monad instance for the future option
we can call our abstract translate and
we can see how we can translate a subset
of the routes and then seal it so we can
translate HTTP routes or we can
translate an entire application our
Translate middleware now works across
whatever context that you're in so now
you can do it partially or you can do it
totally that's pretty cool while we were
looking at closley it's good we adopted
this new type and when I adopt a new
type I like to start to look through the
source code and say ok what else does
this type do for me
and going through the course code and
closely I see this strange thing a
client semi-group Kay I don't know what
a semi-group Kay is let's take a look at
it it's this thing that takes an
implicit semi-group for type F but the
signature is really interesting this
looks familiar it looks like something
that we were trying to do before where
you take a cly's li and you take another
cly's Li and you get a cly's Li back and
the name of it is combined kay let's see
what's going on here so we go to the
cats Docs and we see an explanation of
it but a semi-group Kay option if
something that's universally quantified
it's a way of combining together two
options and the only way that you can
combine those options as by or else
thing them together so if we look at the
shape of this this looks like something
that we're trying to do taking a cly's
Li and another cly's Li and combining
them into one cly's Li and it has or
else like semantics this sounds very
familiar so let's see what
go ahead and define an instance of
semi-group K for future option we're
gonna play a little bit of type Tetris
and see if we can come up with something
that matches that signature and what we
see here up on the screen works where we
call the value we flat me up into it if
there's some value that's the one that
we want if there isn't the value if the
first one returned none X returned none
then we want to call off to Y and return
that future option so that gives us or
else like semantics inside of a future
and now we've got our English service
we've got our Spanish service we've got
our combi 9k which was provided by the
Clive way
and the seal so we've gotten rid of that
old combine function that we had that's
something that's built-in as long as we
have an instance for a context that's
built in directly and we got that for
free from cats by using these standard
types and now when we post to hola
we find hola Boston again so it works
but now our CFO was angry at us he says
90% of our users speak English but we're
seeing 10 times the bill from our
translation service that we expect I
need you to look into that okay we're
gonna write a logging middleware we're
gonna write a logging middleware that
says that we're translating and then we
wrap it so before we make our call to
translate we're also going to wrap that
in log so our definition of our Spanish
service has changed let's see what's
going on there
we run a unit test and we post a hello
let's look at the definition of our
service again we should be hitting the
English service first it's defined for
hello so we should be able to get a
response out of that we shouldn't fall
through to the Spanish service and the
service is working as far as the user is
concerned they're getting the correct
responses but we can see that
side-effect has happened in the
background we're calling that
translation service even though we're
never considering that response because
we got that response from the first
service the problem that we have here is
that future is eager and what we're
doing when we're doing responses is we
might be doing side effects to create
our responses we don't want to be doing
side effects for no good we want to be
very controlled about how we got our
side effects this one is merely wasteful
but imagine that we were doing something
that was doing just something
destructive like deleting something from
a database if you were accidentally
running that we'd have an even bigger
problem we wouldn't just have the CFO
angry
we have customer service angry at us too
so we need to do better
so future is something served us pretty
well we need that asynchronicity but we
need something beyond that we need
something that's lazier than a future
and cats effect he has something to say
about this it has this type class called
sink sink is an extension of ammonia
that he adds a little bit of extra
functionality and the key thing that
we're looking for here is that a sink is
a monad that could suspend the execution
of side effects into the eff context and
future isn't sink you can't suspend a
future when you construct a future it
starts running right away so what we
need is we need a new type and IO is a
type that's also provided by Kats effect
it behaves in a lot of ways like a
future so you can do is you can model
asynchronous processes you can compose
things without falling into callbacks
you can flat me up over them just like
you can with the future but it also has
this way of delaying a side effect until
it's evaluated at the end of the world
at the end of the world is something
that you hear about a lot in functional
programming so the end of the world it
can be the end of your main method in
the case of our slide back here the end
of the world is our unit tests that's a
common end of the world or in the
context of an HTTP server back-end
the end of the world is the end of the
request cycle where you're running the
response that your service returned
those are all ends of the world but
we're able to delay those effects until
they happen let's redefine our service
now so instead of having a future option
everywhere that we saw a future before
we now see i/o that's the only
difference
that's cool that was a pretty simple
translation but now we've got a new
hassle because remember we had a monad
we had to define a monad for future
options so we could do composition we
had to define a semi-group case so we
could do combination of services and
we've got to do all of that again for
i/o so I don't want to dwell on this
slide out slide I want to keep moving
things along so we're going to move
quickly if you want to implement your
this yourself if you're just getting
used to the style of programming
implementing this type is a really good
exercise for you if you ought to just
look at it and stare and learn I'll be
posting these slides later and if you
don't want to learn about it and forget
it existed wait a couple minutes because
we're about to make it unnecessary all
right so now we've redefined our service
instead of
inside a future we're inside of IO IO
applied delays the side effect that you
pass to it so that's the only real
change here also our logging middleware
has changed it now takes a sync
constraint so we're delaying the side
effect of saying that we've translated
that was something that was missing from
our previous model and now when we
posted the hello endpoint we can see
that we still get the correct response
and we also see that the translate is
not running now that we're lazy in our
effects we're only running them when we
need them our CFO is off our back
everything is good it was kind of a drag
though that we had to define we've gone
through this exercise of hand crafting
these instances for a future option and
handcrafting these op instances for an
IO option if we decide there's some
shiny new type out there we're going to
have to go through this exercise again
it seems like that's something that
should be generic and it is chance
provides this data type called option T
and what it is is a white wrapper on an
F of option A which is exactly what we
have we had a future of an option a we
had an IO of an option a those are all
instances of an F of option a so what an
option T is is it's a monad transformer
so you take an option and you can bury
it inside of another monad and this is a
very convenient wrapper that gives you a
monad instance it gives you a sink
instance alt sinks or monads it also
gives you a semi-group K instance so if
we can express our services in terms of
option T then we get all those things
for free so version 8 of our service
we're going to redefine things our HTTP
app is still unchanged or no I'm sorry
our HTTP app is changed we're now
parameter izing HTTP app over some base
monad we're no longer committing to i/o
and one reason that we're no longer
committing to i/o is we want to be able
to use this option T so HTTP app and
HTTP routes those now are also
parameterize on their context we're
going to call that the base monad and
for an HTTP app that's just an HTTP
function that is in the base monad you
need an i/o out and then for HTTP routes
we're going to say it's an option T over
F and IO is going to be the common
construction for that let's take a look
at that now when we define our routes we
have to say that what our base monad is
so IO we've had to add that but in
exchange for that we've gotten rid
of all those artisanally handcrafted
instances and when we run that we can
see that we post to it and our service
works well inside of an option T our
hello service is interesting note that
it's parameterize now over F our hello
service doesn't refer to IO anymore and
it seems like we paid a lot of cost
there to get rid of just having to
define those instances because you
define those instances once and you
forget it so maybe that was expensive
but we did get something pretty neat out
of this
so there's another library out there
called monix and monix is getting a lot
of attention lately there's a really
great blog post this morning by
alexandre he's the primary author of
monix that compares io to another type
that monix provide is called a task and
there are some various things io is a
little bit simpler to ask you has some
different ideas on scheduling fairness
and things like that they're both really
great types the neat thing is now that
we've defined our service that way in
terms of type classes and parameterize
types as all we need to do to have
monarch support as everywhere we said IO
before we said task boom we have monarch
support so you can pick your base Monia
depending on what level of complexity
and dependencies that you want and it
will work as long as you have a sync
instance as long as you have a
semi-group k instance you're ready to go
let's move on to another problem that we
have with our service so in honor of
being in Boston I'd like to translate
the midnight ride of Paul Revere so
we're going to define an application
where we post to the translate endpoint
we had something like this on an earlier
slide but now we're all parameterised
over F it's a little bit different than
it was before
when I tried to translate the midnight
ride to power of year I get a little bit
uncomfortable so I am an engineer I'm
not a humanities major I have no idea
how long the midnight ride of Paul
Revere is is it a few paragraphs is it a
thousand pages I don't remember
I'm an engineer what I do know is that
it's longer than my slide and as a
server operator I'm already really
uncomfortable because what I see is I'm
not getting any incremental output I
have to wait for the entire Paul
Revere's midnight ride to be translated
before I get any response and yeah I
also have to worry that it's buffering
that entire response into memory I need
to worry about the memory consumption on
my server HTTP has this concept of
transfer encoding so you're able to
start emitting results before you have
fully computed the response is able to
give you incremental updates and then
the end gives you an empty trunk and
that's how you know that an HTTP
response is done we should have an HTTP
library that supports that so we're
going to change up our request on our
response a little bit we're going to
replace the string body that we had
before with a stream and our streaming
implementation is going to be FS - I
don't have time to give a full overview
of FS - and how that works a Fabio will
be talking about that later we're just
going to hand wave it a little bit and
see what it buys us basically what a
stream does is it provides you an output
type so we're going to have a stream of
bytes and those can be evaluated in some
F context and the reason the stream has
an F context is so that way you can
track your side effects because you can
materialize the stream say you want to
read a file that's something that
happens inside of i/o so you would have
a stream of i/o - byte FS - gives you a
whole bunch of functions for doing that
sort of thing so every stream it has an
effect and it has an output type and
when we put that F there on our body
that meant that we had to put a type
parameter on request in response we have
to declare what type of effect the
request and the response run in probably
running out of time here so let's do our
final version of what an HTTP app and
HTTP routes are so now we're going to
see our HTTP client it actually operates
in two contexts so it's got an F and
what the f is is a representation of
what effect the response has turned in
and then the G as a representation of
what effect the stream runs in and when
we think about an HTTP app what we want
that to be is we want there to be a
wrapper of a request in some effect F 2
and F of some response in effect F and
what that expresses as that expresses a
total function so we can run the effects
of the request we can decode it into
some F type and then we can map over
that F type and then we get an F
response out that's something that works
out very nicely HTTP routes we still
need that concept of optionality so what
we're doing there is we're applying the
option monad transformer to the request
effect type so HTTP routes ends up being
an option transformer F the syntax you
see here is provided by
kind projector by the way I failed to
mention that earlier now let's redefine
our service let's say we've got a
streaming back-end in addition to our
future base back-end so right here in
the middle on that line body through now
that we've got a binary body what we do
is we take that body and we need to
decode that we're going to go from a
stream of F to byte to a stream of F to
strings and those are going to be
English strings and we're going to pass
it to our translators service and that's
going to be a pipe that goes from a
stream of strings to another stream of
strings but it'll be English streams
coming in and Spanish streams coming out
and then we're going to run that through
the utf-8 encoder because we need to go
back to bytes HTTP bodies are a binary
protocol by default so we need to encode
those on the way out that's our call to
streaming back-end and now to run this
what we can see as we call the app we're
going to build up a request instead of
Paul Revere's midnight ride as a strict
body we're going through stream Paul
Revere's midnight ride because again I'm
an engineer I don't remember how long it
is now we take that i/o response and to
actually deal with this this is an
example of dealing with FS to code we're
not going to go too deep into this if
you like this please come to fabio's
talk later today we're going to lift
that IO response into a stream of
response now we flat me up that to get
the body we decode that to get strings
we're going to take the first five lines
that come off of it we're gonna compile
it down to a list when we get that list
inside of some context we're going to
map that down to make a string to jam it
all together and now we've got an F of a
string remember everything is a delayed
side-effect now we're at the end of the
world at the end of the world we can
call unsafe or unsink and when we do
that we can see the first 5 lines of the
translation of Paul Revere's midnight
ride so we can see that we're getting
things incrementally now and we're
getting things in constant space maybe
if Paul Revere's midnight ride is they
actually thousands of pages long maybe
it's still translating they're on the
back end I don't care I got what I
needed out of this right away so now I'd
like to talk about some libraries that
are out there in the ecosystem so we're
using all these types and cats and cats
effect in fs2 and those all solve some
real problems for us but what's really
nice is when you get the network effect
and use some other things that are out
there in the ecosystem so I'm
give a brief tour of a couple other
libraries and show all they all snap
together so a lot of the applications
they need a configuration so pure config
it's a wrapper around pipe safe config
we can see an example of a JDBC
configuration there for pure config and
what pure config does is it Maps case
classes to our configurations defined
and type safe config it has the Katz
effect integration when you think about
configuration it's something that can
fail for a variety of reasons it can
feel because you're reading it off the
disk and disks can feel and it can feel
more commonly because you've got a typo
and you're often this uncompelled thing
and you've got a typo and it doesn't
make up cleanly to your case class and
anything that can feel that's what we
want to wrap it in IO type one of the
things that we get from an i/o type as
bad things can happen inside of this so
it's convenient to be able to load up a
config as an i/o so hold that thought
another library that snaps nicely
together is do be it's written by Rob
Norris one of our MCS here
Dubey has this notion of a trans actor
you can think of a trans actor as a way
of doing connection management it gives
you connections it runs things that
cleans up the connection for you so you
don't have to think about all those
triple e nested JDBC blocks that you
used to have to do and then we've got
this numbers query so we pass the trans
actor to numbers and do B also has this
insight that a jdbc resultset in an FS
to stream or things that fit together
very well because it's an effect 'full
thing it's something that happens in IO
it's not referentially transparent so
you want to put that in IO and it's
something where you might get it
unreasonably large result set so it's
convenient to be able to treat those as
a stream so you're able to take an
arbitrary query we have the type that
the query returns we return a stream and
we call trans actor on it and it gives
us the echo stream so that's cool
further tutorial on do bees out of scope
but it has the basic shape that we need
john fs2 is a little library that I
wrote so John is a library that comes
from Eric awesome who's also here John
is an incremental JSON parser very often
you're going to have very large JSON
bodies that are wrapped either inside of
an array or maybe their new line
delimited and you can parse those
incrementally you want to start getting
the values out one by one so I wrote
something that was a wrapper around John
that takes that incremental
output and turns it into an FS to stream
as well and that's a call comes from
this unwrapped JSON array that we see
here and we're able to take that and in
receiving session it would be a better
demo if this JSON were really big but
we're able to print those out one by one
as we parse those let's try to put this
all together so these types that I've
been talking about so far the HTTP app
and HTTP routes those are something that
will be coming in HTTP for us 1.0 the
design is coming together on that I was
up late with Chris Davenport last night
talking about that actually what we're
going to see here is going to be based
on the production version of HTTP 4s
that's open eighteen point three and we
have this concept of an HTTP service we
don't have a distinction between apps
and routes right now everything returns
an option and we make the responsibility
of sealing off that service something
that the backend has to implement so the
type here is a little bit different but
we're going to see something that is an
actual real honest HTTP service so what
we do is we pass it a bunch of routes so
we're going to take a request we're not
going to be picky we're just going to
respond to all requests with this we're
going to call that numbers query from
Dubey recall that that returns a stream
of tuples from integers to the names and
then we're going to use Cersei where
we're going to use JSON literals and
we're going to take that tuple and
encode it as a JSON and now at that
point what do we have well we mapped
over a stream of tuples to a stream of
JSON so now we have a stream of JSON
HTTP for SA has this idea of entity
encoders and entity decoders so for a
lot of common types it knows how to take
those types and serialize and
deserialize those into a stream of bytes
so all we need to do is say we're going
to respond okay and we're going to take
the stream of JSON and that's something
that we know how to encode into a stream
of bytes so now we've got our F of
response to F or our IO of response to
IO in this case and now let's put it all
together so this program everything you
see on the right hand side this is all
in a for comprehension is going to
operate in the IO context we're going to
put it all together and see if we can
build a program so we're going to load
the config as we discussed via pure
config that happens inside of IO
we're going to create a do be trans
actor
to an h2 database this entire slideshow
as compiled so everything that you see
here is real we're going to create an
in-memory database and then we're going
to set it up with sorry for our doobie
example we're going to call setup that's
just something we need to do because
we're inside of a slideshow to make it
all tick and then inside of our
slideshow we're going to start a server
so we're going to use our native blaze
back-end for that the way you do that in
HTTP for s is with a blaze builder we're
going to mount that application the
application has a dependency on the
trans actor so it's app and then we
apply the XA to it we're going to bind
that to port 8080 and we're going to
start that that's going to give us an IO
of a server that start name is maybe a
little bit misleading it doesn't
actually start the server right away it
gives you an IO server and an HTTP one
client that's how we create a client in
HTTP for s we're going to create a
request which is just going to be a get
request to localhost port 8080 and then
on our client API we call fetch we pass
it the request and then as part of the
HTTP for us client API you need to give
it a callback of the response and that
callback is something that returns an IO
of some type it's dealing with the
response and then you have to fully
consume the response inside of that
callback because once that IO type or
whatever F context you're operating in
completes we need to be able to release
the connection for connection pooling
reasons that's why it's designed the way
that it is and that parse response we
call this helper here that calls the
John FS - that takes however big a JSON
it is and starts to incrementally spit
things out and then when everything is
done we shut down the client and we shut
down the server and at the end we should
have a list of the first three JSON
elements that get output by this service
we call it and we run it and there it is
we fired up a server
we've hired up a client and we started
streaming results from the database grab
the first three and shut everything down
cleanly so that's how it all fits
together
I had a bonus talking point here in case
I talk too fast looking at the clock I
did not talk too fast but I just want to
briefly hand wave at this this is
something that's really interesting to
me
user ed Amara vid came up with this I
hope I'm pronouncing that correctly he
observed that
can't ammonia does something that ends
up looking a lot like the akka HTTP
directives so if you're writing akka
HTTP services but you're interested in
this functional style of programming
this might be something where we can
pull that in and then you would have
HTTP directives would be something
inside of a conte an HTTP applied to
conte and then we'd be able to do all
this composition in combination just the
same as you can with routing it's an
alternative way of looking at routing I
thought it was a neat observation
acknowledgments we've got a lot of
maintainer zuv HTTP for estimated out
here today some of these people look a
lot like their avatar some of these
people look nothing like their avatar
some of these people came from very far
away some of these people made the
grueling trip all the way up from Rhode
Island
but anyway I owe a great deal of
gratitude to all of these people and I
suggest you go meet these people if you
haven't they are all wonderful and I'm
very thankful for everything they've
contributed to the project finally I
said I don't like to talk about myself I
do like to talk about my work because
I'm very excited about my work I'm
working at formation one thing that I've
heard quite a bit over the course of
this week is oh you're doing Haskell now
that's true I am doing high school but
we also do a lot of Scala so if you're
interested in doing functional Scala if
you're interested in transitioning to
Haskell or in my case I'm interested in
doing a mix if you're interested in
doing a mix and you'd like to apply that
to machine learning or big data and you
don't want to move to San Francisco I
still live in Indiana or remote friendly
if any of that appeals to you we are
hiring for all those positions and a lot
of locations and I would love to talk to
you alright that's all I have
you